football is dividing America in half
half of this country wants to talk about
issues that are taking place outside of
the field things like race and equality
and police brutality things that affect
everyday Americans and half the country
just wants to talk about flags
uncomplicated two-dimensional flags
because what President Trump is saying
and what these protesters don't seem to
get is that America is actually more
important than amira
cants it's America first and to finish
that thought Americans second America
listen up Americans are complicated with
issues and problems and allegations of
systemic racism these are things that
make me sad America on the other hand is
unimpeachable it's flawless and easy to
find on a map that makes me happy
America is coleslaw hotdogs monster
trucks and footballs the idea of America
is what needs protecting that flag has
been perfect ever since Betsy Ross sewed
those 50 stars on to it back in 1777
she knew that America never needed to
change it just needed to be protected
and I like to think that when those New
England Patriots took the field against
those regular England Redcoats none of
them were kneeling but now America is
facing an enemy even scarier than a
malnourished Brit with a musket
Americans and we here at the opposition
feel that we are the first line of
defense for you people of America
against Americans protesting America
so here are some effective ways to
reclaim football and make it
uncomplicated and enjoyable Oppo tip 1
just watch the games in Reverse that way
players are so moved by the national
anthem that they stand up and run
backwards in the locker room also most
of the game is just a bunch of players
hugging and then jumping away from each
other into organized formations Oppo tip
number two we created this great photo
filter over at the shop position that
gives kneeling players legs your
favorite players may seem a little
shorter but at least those jacked
Bilbo's will respect the flag hop Oh tip
3 forget football it's ruined we need a
new even more American sport a sport
that won't waste players legs kneeling
in fact we'll get them standing and
using their legs at all times
also ditch the pads and helmets
Americans we aren't afraid of a little
rough-and-tumble plus a football has two
pointy ends and after this whole debacle
I'm sick and tired of points make that
ball round now yes there's a football
that Americans can get behind it's going
to be huge